all right the war of words it's a whole
new level it's president Trump unleashes
on the media and one of his fiercest
attacks yet the president slamming much
of the press on Twitter today as quote
totally dishonest who says he says don't
care for the truth writing fake books
and using anonymous sources that are
pure fiction
this comes after Trump blasted CNN and
veteran journalist Carl Bernstein over
the networks Trump Tower report the
president saying the network has been
caught in a major lie CNN and Bernstein
firing back at the president saying they
stand by their reporting Greg lots of
tweets overnight low lots of tweets I'm
glad he was tweeting about this and not
about the funeral but he Trump is like a
heckler behind the dugout he senses he
can sense the central weakness of the
pitcher and in this case the pitcher is
CNN and he won't stop until the guy
throws the mitt down and runs to the
stands to fight and he's getting that
and he's what he's doing is he's giving
CNN the CNN treatment because they made
that meeting story into a relentless
bombshell every newscaster was having a
conniption about it and now that story
seems to be falling apart in Trump is
giving CNN the relentless falling apart
story and he won't let go so now I think
it's even steven and last point whenever
I get like a little bit upset or annoyed
about the tweeting I remember that the
media spent decades punching at
conservatives for decades probably since
the Vietnam War now somebody is punching
back and they're crying foul so I it's
hard for me to sympathize for the media
when they're complaining since they had
a in the left have been essentially
interchangeable since Vietnam we're
going to need a lot of Trump tweets to
kind of even the score first he liked
that he didn't like that one no I did
even if I was on the right I would say
oh so rush limbaugh to William F Buckley
didn't exist there's no conservative
thought expressed - nothing like this oh
not like now I mean coming out coming at
you like I mean obviously Twitter's a
new vehicle so that's right yeah but I
think I mean to me what was incredible
was in the middle of a funeral for a
statesman John McCain what's our
president doing he's not saying oh you
know my thoughts my prayers with fan no
no he's attacking CNN he is so obsessed
them that right in the middle of him to
like this because it's not only the
story Lawrence because the story is it's
well he tells a lot of I mean this has
been the media near-death that they are
there to hold the president accountable
they should have a reason why they are
losing credibility with the American
people why their approval rate is lower
than Congress is because they don't tell
the truth sometimes it's a simple fix
I don't tell American people hey we
messed up on this we issue a retraction
that Emily because CNN says they're
standing by their stories I imagine that
this having gone in journalism schools
that that's because they say they have
another source and could could it might
not be true but I don't imagine that
they are totally lying about this yeah I
mean I my biggest issue with this is the
fact that of course the president can
take issue with any organization that he
thinks the skewing coverage of him that
has called his a malignant
administration whatever but I think at a
certain point it's beneath the office of
the presidency and to me like everything
it's distracting and when this becomes
the story then it's totally detracting
from what really is the story to me
which is the fact that this large-scale
investigation is being undertaken right
now with our tax dollars and is either
pursuing nefarious conduct or it's
furthering nefarious conduct and we have
a ton of unanswered questions about
intelligence gathering protocol and
breaks and chain of command and the
interplay between the DOJ and FBI and
Congress and this administration and
whether uncorroborated unverified
information is being relied upon by law
enforcement and potentially the courts
and then being leaked tactically by
officials in the government that our
rogue so to me these are all the larger
questions and when the story becomes the
social media warfare or media warfare it
just does everyone is I think that's all
a great conspiracy theory because I
think if you're going to say that so
many judges the FBI run by a Republican
the Department of Justice run by problem
but here's the thing to me he's that
he's going on about alternative facts
fake news oh gee I wonder what the FBI
had to say this week when he picked up
on some conservatives you know report Oh
Hillary Clinton's emails were hacked by
the Chinese the FBI comes out I mean I
guess it's some political risk to
themselves given this president's antics
and says no
there's no evidence that Hillary
Clinton's emails were ever hacked and
then he goes there any mother Chinese he
didn't go to journalism school then he
goes after Lester Holt on the on the
Olli I have god forbid Lester Holt Oh
Lester hope fudge that this is the first
time we've ever heard that there's any
problem so exactly who has a trouble
telling the truth I think it's not NBC
not CNN I think it's one guy named one
watt I think most of America understands
that Trump plays fast and loose with the
facts but he's generally directionally
right what position did exactly
exaggerate every single thing the
question is though is it the media's job
to be doing this I mean CNN literally
calls him a racist every single night
and so what is the President and they do
this at every Republican I did this is
George Bush as well the difference with
Donald Trump is that he responds and his
base loves it
there are some times that I would agree
that the president gets off base with
his sweet I think we can all agree with
that but enlarge when it comes to the
media it's a winning issue for the
president that's why he continues to
fight this I don't know that it's a
winning issue we'll see but I mean to me
it's like he just is a snowflake
president he's got a grievance and he
can't get beyond I hope he's watching
right now I coming at you want to okay
the 19th separate in 1970s will be known
for disco the 80s was known for like
Betamax again yet Oh Reagan well big
hair the 90s was grunge
I think the teens which is what this is
will be known for Trump's tweets this is
the thing that everybody looks back at
Twitter yeah and everybody will be
laughing about it because well it'll be
something that either came and went or
established something about the on your
podcast yesterday you interviewed his
name Jerry Eisenberg Eisenberg and one
of the things this is a great podcast by
the way this he created he did all the
creations for did the Jetsons
Flintstones Scooby Doo one of the things
he said that he loved the most is
working on the Flintstones because he
could I'm sorry the Jetsons because he
could use his imagination and basically
he invented Skype yeah yeah like video
or FaceTime yeah but he didn't invent
Twitter no he didn't is the one thing
that nobody saw coming yeah I did no no
no no when I was in second grade I used
to write on the bathroom wall anonymous
stuff about people in my class that's
Twitter that is also another point of us
if he's the prince complaining about
anonymous sources which every president
complains about but every White House
asked to be quoted on background for
certain things he talked about a fake
book I imagine that could be Bob
Woodward's book that is coming out
September 11th but but also remember he
also used to be his own anonymous source
here in New York City that was great oh
sorry but I feel like he's partly this
is why he's used to what he's used to
drive in the narrative and asking these
questions and I don't understand why he
is expected again I think there's a
certain amount of decorum associated
with the office that we'd like him to
hold but I don't understand why
challenging the coverage and challenging
these questions means that he should
have a target on him for doing so and
regardless of the method because I do
think it's important to ask those
questions and for him to say look why
aren't you covering this or cover this
fairly or why am I not getting the
benefit of the doubt when X has happened
and why Twitter is a great tool for him
and one of the things he could have
tweeted today was check this out workers
51 percent of workers in America say
they are happy that's the first time and
I never helped any yet why does he do
it's not him you know what it is
Trump was radicalized by something okay
cuz he was a Democrat for a long time he
was fairly he was pro-choice liberal and
many things he was radicalized what was
he radicalized by US Fox News in Fox
News when Fox News happened you started
watching Fox News to make sense to him
and then so all he's doing one is what
we do which is we pass the media so he's
just doing he's turned the White House
and to kind of like an alternative Fox
show
[Laughter]
no I'm actually no I'm actually saying
it's kind of refreshing no Chuck Todd of
NBC said it it's like one of those old
guys going down the sidewalk mumbling to
himself except he has a million-plus
Twitter Fox just jealous of his hair oh
yeah well I think that part of this is
that the president wants had a great
relationship with the media as well
yeah and they turned on yeah all the way
into the primary they all wanted him to
win and now I wanted him to do it
exactly and everyone was screaming to
covered him everybody wanted the latest
interview and then they flipped on and
so I think the president is also ticked
off about that